et parallèlement à ce scrutin
présidentiel les discussions se
poursuivent donc à vienne en autriche où
se situe le siège de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
aiea et l'iran qui se sont accordés pour
maintenir les installations nucléaires
iraniennes jusqu'au 24 juin
autour de la table depuis de nombreuses
semaines téhéran washington moscou pékin
paris londres et berlin
objectif à un retour des états unis au
sein de l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien signé en 2015 les américains se
sont retiré unilatéralement en mai 2018
sous le mandat de donald trump
depuis cette date l'iran se désengage
régulièrement de ses obligations prévues
dans le texte devienne surnommé le jcp
hoa et en direct dans ce gîte et pour
parler de l'iran gérard vespière
analyste géopolitique et chercheur
associé à la fée - la fondation d'études
pour le moyen-orient
bonjour gérer un vestiaire remercier
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ou
ensemble les négociations à vienne lui
d'abord il y a deux types de
négociations vaines négociations
j'irai technique entre l'iran et puis la
chance à internationale de l'énergie
atomique et une négociation entre l'iran
et les puissances internationales
donc la première à concerne les sites à
visiter concerne les périodes de visite
concerne le délai entre la visite et le
souhait exprimé par les inspecteurs donc
à un certain nombre de caractéristiques
techniques de procédure cette dernière
qui vient donc de donner un délai de
supplémentaire d'un mois pour une
activité à accepter des deux parties sur
la visite des sites
maintenant reste la deuxième négociation
qui concerne donc les accords
internationaux et donc on a quelques
échos d'avancé mais pour le moment rien
de concret vraiment l'oeil a été en
prolonger jusqu'au 24 rejoint donc le
programme d'inspection venait d'en
parler des installations nucléaires
iraniennes
à quoi correspondent elles exactement 7
lang à sion et comment est-ce qu'elle va
se matérialiser sur le terrain et bien
il y avait une première un premier
accord qui avait eu lieu le 21 février
pour trois mois
donc c'était les iraniens qui avaient
donné ce délai de validation et donc 21
février 21 mai n est cependant qu il y
avait besoin d'une prolongation et il y
a un jeu subtil de communication des
iraniens à savoir faire dans la
négociation pour avoir l'impression ou
donner l'impression que ce sont eux qui
ont les clés ce sont eux qui donnent le
timing c'est eux qui donnent le tempo
dans leur approbation
donc cela est bien calibrée et c'est le
souci donc le souhait de l'iran de
donner cette impression de communication
que c'est eux qui ont les clés de la
situation à d'où leur décision un peu
tardive d'où leur décision d'un délai
raccourci passé le 18 juin on l'a dit
c'est la date de l'élection
présidentielle est passé le 24 rejoint
d'être de cette prolongation
qu'est ce qui va se passer après ces
deux dates selon vous eh bien il va se
passer qui va se passer maintenant
plus exactement c'est est-ce que entre
la date du 28 29 mai et puis
effectivement fin juin va-t-il y avoir
des avancées dans les négociations à
savoir une acceptation par téhéran de
réduire son taux d'enrichissement une
acceptation par téhéran de réduire son
taux d'uranium en son volume son stock
d'uranium enrichi à une acceptation par
terre en de réduire son volume d'eau
lourde
donc voilà il s'agit de voir comment
allaient les profils techniques de
l'accord peuvent se mettre en place et
de l'autre côté les puissances
occidentales à la chine et la russie
d'accepter donc un desserrement des
sanctions mais elle la présidentielle
qui va se jouer prochainement en iran
est ce qu'elle peut influer sur les
décisions qui vont être prises à vienne
je pense que c'est un peu le contraire
je pense que sont les décisions qui
seront prises à vienne ou pas prises à
vienne
qui vont avoir une influence sur
l'élection est là donc il ya une carte
que les puissances occidentales vont
dans la main à savoir est ce que
j'essaye de when they said de bâtir un
accord avant l'élection présidentielle
et donc de donner un une accélération
aux relations entre l'iran et
l'international donc de favoriser a
finalement un score de participation
on vient elle n'ira pas d'accord et donc
que vous voulez le signaler dans votre
préambule la situation interne en iran
va prévaloir à savoir les difficultés
économiques des difficultés sociales
les retraités sont très souvent dans la
rue et aussi les difficultés sanitaires
il faut savoir que les chiffres
officiels de décès sont complètement je
dirais contrecarrée par les chiffres
annoncés par là la résistance iranienne
qui frôle les 300 mille décès liés au co
vide
donc il y a vraiment un ressentiment
profond dans l'acide dans la société
iranienne contre le régime quels sont
les leviers de négociation de téhéran de
washington et même des autres partis les
leviers c'est effectivement une côté
iranien la continuité ou la continuation
de l' escalade technique en disant nous
allons mettre encore plus de
centrifugeuses en place nous allons
encore augmenter notre taux
d'enrichissement et de l'autre côté et
bien la prolongation du côté des
puissances occidentales en particulier
des états unis le maintien des sanctions
dont l'absence pratiquement
d'exportation iranienne de pétrole qui
prive les l'iran de 2 milliards de
milliards et demi de ventes de pétrole
par mois n'est ce pas donc là où nous
parlons de chiffres tout à fait
conséquents pour l'économie iranienne
mais elle n'est pas en difficulté
seulement à cause de cela elle est en
difficulté parce que le pays vit au
dessus de ses moyens en s'impliquant
liban en s'appliquant s'il y en
s'impliquant lourdement
on ira qu'on est en aidant les outils ou
yémen donc depuis des dizaines d'années
c'est ça vraiment la difficulté
fondamentale de l'économie iranienne et
non pas seulement les sanctions
américaines
merci jean ravet ce fier d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes géopolitologue et chercheur associé
à la fée mot la fondation d'études pour
le moyen-orient